Hey, welcome back. So, we're working on
a Honda CRV. It's a 2018. We have a turn
key. We have one working key, one key at
home, and we're going to make a new key.
So, we're going to use our Altel K100 to
add key. The Smart Pro would just delete
it. Check out the links below to see
that comparison on how the machines
work. Um, so let's get started. We have
one program key and then one non-program
key. Let's go ahead and turn the vehicle
on. Give it some juice.
And let's go to our options and let's do
automatic
selection. Let's
read. Cool.
Okay. And it's a blade
key. Cool. There's information.
Yes. Cool. And let's do hot function.
Okay, turn the ignition on. So, I'm
going to turn it off and just to the on
mode. And also, if you're using the Alto
508, check out the links. I have another
turnkey for that. Um, similar, just
different machines, but similar
process, just takes a little longer.
Okay, cool. And this is where the Alt
tell series is really cool. We have add
key, all keys lost, erase key. Let's do
add
key. Cool. There's our information.
Let's go ahead and
start. Insert the registered key. It's
already in
there.
Okay. Okay. Turn it
off. Turn it on.
[Music]
Okay. Would you like to learn the next
one?
Yes. So, turn
off. Insert the new key. So, I'm going
to take out original. Grab the new key.
In
on. Okay.
No. Cool. And we turn
off. Turn back
[Music]
on. Turn
off. Is the mobilizer light out? Yes,
it's out.
[Music]
Cool. So you went from two keys. So we
have one here and one at home. Now we
have three keys. Cool. And we are
done. We can crank it
on. And we have one original
key and another key. So, we
have Cool. And we're good to
go. Other than that, have a great day
and I'll see you next time. See you.
Bye.